[Music]
so Kelty remember a couple months ago
when this shot of Rihanna and Donald
Glover went viral and folks went bananas
yeah well it happened again after Donald
week scenes of their mysterious project
guava island during a movie festival in
New Zealand yes people are so hyped
about footage from the film that someone
shot on a movie screen that has gone
viral you're telling me that they made
an entire movie and nobody knew about it
it's only Rihanna can do that you know I
mean she's amazing but there is actually
another movie featuring Donald lovers
voice that's got everyone talking and me
crying Disney's live-action The Lion
King and here is everything we know it
was this first glimpse of Simba in
Disney's Lion King live-action remake
that got over 224 million views globally
in just 24 hours
that makes it Disney's most watched
trailer ever in a day the film doesn't
hit theaters until July of next year but
this is what et knows first the future
Queen Nala will be played by the
reigning queen beep you've been lying to
you Donald Glover who plays Simba told
et what it was like recording those
classics with her like so hear the
lyrics I'm like don't worry like I was
in fourth grade this gave out et knows
the film will mirror the original 1994
story in fact the teaser trailer is
essentially a shot-for-shot remake of
the Films opening sequence
[Music]
we know seth rogen will bring his own
spin to Pumbaa the Warthog which means
we'll sing this iconic song it's amazing
for many reasons one is because I am a
big fan of blanking too because it's
like the most expensive movie I'll ever
have anything to do is probably so
that's thrilling overall it's it's
surreal it'll be weird wouldn't it when
it comes out the animated movie was
great
the play was unbelievable this movie
looks like you've changed your life the
Lion King hits theaters July 19th of
2019 and then I go
[Music]
[Applause]